almost anything narrated by david
attenborough is always going to be
fascinating and inspiring however there
was one moment from the series dynasties
in particular that stuck with me in it
an alpha chimpanzee called david is
starting to lose his authority as he
gets older eventually he is overthrown
in a harrowing scene assaulted by a gang
of younger chimps that bite and strike
him and leave him for dead
even the camera crew find this upsetting
but like uh they cannot interfere
they continue to film him as he lies on
the ground
motionless
for days
[Music]
but amazingly david starts to move again
and slowly he regains his strength in
fact he regains his strength enough that
he's able to return to his group and
retake the throne by force
i'm not sure to what extent these
stories are fabricated but there is
clearly some truth here and what really
struck me is the way in which david was
able to recover his strength i can't
imagine a human being being left for
dead in the wilderness and recovering to
such an extent for many of us a twisted
ankle is a life sentence issues like bad
shoulders or knees can end up haunting
us for years or even decades
in the wild a limp like that would
severely hamper our ability to hunt for
food procreate and survive
here in the 21st century tennis elbow or
shoulder impingement can hamper our
training to the point that we lose all
gains and possibly even our enthusiasm
for training at all
moreover such issues can make regular
movement painful and difficult but
that's precisely the difference david
doesn't have the option to take it easy
he doesn't have any means to elevate his
injuries or apply ice he just had to get
on with it
if you have a bad knee so you completely
stop using your knee what message do you
think you're sending to your body
simple that you don't need to use that
knee and so it's not worth the resources
for your body to repair it
not only that but you will invite a
cascade of compensatory movement
patterns and imbalances that can lead to
further issues down the line
counter-intuitively the best way to heal
is actually to keep training but you
need to be smart about it
and at the same time this will help to
mitigate any loss of gains
in fact you might just find you improve
in ways you didn't even expect
so how do you train smart when injured
well not to brag but i get injured all
the time
mostly because filming the bioneer often
means pushing myself to get a shot even
when my body is saying stop also i fall
off stuff
speaking with my wife the last time she
was disinfecting my back like a scene
from lethal weapon i told her that i
learned an important lesson from this
latest fall
that i can heal from anything and i was
now ready to provide caution entirely to
the wind i will never die
that's not precisely what i think she
was hoping to hear
definitely be cautious people but there
is a strategy to continue training
safely through injury and i plan on
showing that here
let's start with what you don't do and
that is to move through pain if a
particular range of motion causes you
pain you should simply stop using that
range of motion pain is your body's
warning signal and if you don't heed it
you'll do more damage in the long run
if you imagine a muscle tear like
fraying on an elastic band it certainly
wouldn't be a good idea to then keep
stretching said band to the point of
further fraying
or even snapping
it's also important that you visit a
doctor or someone who knows what they're
talking about and can inspect you in
person
a doctor can advise on the cause of pain
and in some cases there might be
specific treatments that you need to
follow and couldn't have known about
but that's not to say that you shouldn't
move the affected area at all if you
have a regular training injury
in fact moving the affected area is the
best way to get blood flowing to said
area and to encourage healing
this increased blood flow will send
nutrients and building blocks that are
necessary for tissue repair this occurs
in the short term but also in the long
term that can even lead to an increase
in capillary to muscle ratio
that means permanently more blood supply
to that region and another way to think
about a muscle tear is as being similar
to the kind of muscle damage caused by
regular training but to the point of
being maladaptive if you have delayed
onset muscle soreness or doms from
regular training one of the best ways to
combat this is by training the same area
with light weights and high repetitions
the very next day
the same is true for some types of
injury as long as you move through a
range of motion that doesn't cause you
any additional pain
and this is why a lot of studies now
suggest that icing and elevating the
injury as has been recommended for the
longest time can actually slow down
recovery and even prevent full recovery
inflammation is not the enemy normal
inflammation is actually critical for
recovery
inflammation fights infections by
neutrophils and it kick-starts the
healing process by bringing fibroblasts
to produce collagen
and it increases growth hormone
production
in fact the use of anti-inflammatory
drugs may even inhibit hypertrophy
following a normal workout don't take
aspirin for those doms
and studies now suggest that icing
wounds specifically will not only slow
down healing but potentially even reduce
the total amount of recovery
this is still a controversial point and
there are some mixed studies but it
makes a lot of intuitive sense
inflammation is a natural response of
the body and so of course it has a
useful purpose it is not your enemy
walking in other forms of gentle cardio
can also be similarly beneficial by
encouraging blood flow around the entire
body
so the takeaway at this point is to try
training with very light weight or even
no weights at all and a smaller range of
motion that is pain free you can also
use slower movements
over time you should strengthen the
affected area and be able to gradually
increase the weight and return to normal
movement but take it slowly you can also
try blood flow restriction training that
is the correct application for this
particular protocol and it allows you to
increase blood in the target area even
more so while getting more hypertrophy
with lighter weights
studies show that this can indeed
accelerate recovery
either way don't completely stop all
movement
there are more things you can do during
your downtime too for injuries affecting
one limb it's important to continue
training the opposite limb this might
seem like a recipe for imbalance but
fortunately that's not the case thanks
to something called the cross-education
effect
simply this shows that training one limb
will promote strength gains in the
contralateral limb that's the opposite
limb even when that limb isn't being
trained directly this is due to the fact
that you're still training the skill and
building the neural pathways and these
can be referenced when moving the
opposite limb this won't necessarily
promote hypertrophy but you'll be able
to regain that loss size quicker by
maintaining some of your strength
of course you can also use this time to
focus on other areas of your training
for example there's no reason not to
continue training your upper body if you
have an injured leg you might though
find it's useful to use resistance
machines or bands and cables if you
struggle with picking up heavy weights
better yet train things that you
otherwise wouldn't have had the
opportunity to train or the inclination
for example you might benefit from
taking this opportunity to work on your
mobility or to train your grip strength
or to work on cardio we have a tendency
to do a lot of what we're already really
good at so this is the prime time to
work on those weak points
now rather than simply losing gains and
moving backwards you're just redirecting
your energy you're adding to your
arsenal
the best part is that thanks to
adaptations like increased my nuclei
better motor unit recruitment and
stronger tendons your weaker muscles
recover quickly and get to the same
point that are at much more quickly than
they did the first time
in other words once you recover you'll
be back to full strength but now that
added mobility and grip strength
that's how you turn a setback into a win
and for athletes whether you're a
martial artist a tracer a footballer you
might find you're unable to practice the
specific skills you need maybe you can't
jump or throw a run but you can still go
back to basics and work on some
foundational strength or even take the
time to train your brain and your visual
attention
with all that said i would also
recommend against training too
intensively in any capacity even if
you're still able to train hard while
avoiding damaged area it's still a good
idea to scale things back just a little
you really don't have to stop but it's
wise just to go a little easier on
yourself
the reason for this is simply that
recovery itself is something of a
stressor and is resource heavy if you
keep piling on more muscle damage and
challenge onto your body you'll need to
share those resources between those new
adaptations and the healing
and of course sleep well get lots of
sunlight and eat lots
so i hope you found this video useful
and interesting guys if you like this
sort of thing you may enjoy my ebook and
training program super functional
training there i take the same diverse
approach to training to build strength
but also resilience mobility speed
cognitive function and more there's a
link in the description
alternatively you could check out my
print book functional training and
beyond which is a introduction and
discussion around the whole subject of
functional training if you found this
useful then please leave a like and
share around what are your tips for
other people in a similar boat
either way thank you so much for
watching this one guys and i'll see you
soon
thanks for watching and
bye for now
you